[Music]
in math emergency news my whole entire
school career I'll help you I help you
with emergency where I need you guys
good at math in school absolutely not I
thought it was a border really I thought
oh it's horrible and I thought I hated
it
tar everything but I care I cannot
resist my my who I am it's in the heart
it is I just started to do it and I
started to like it and it started to
work and I was like oh no this is not
true I've been resisting this all my
life I don't remember anything past
multiplication oh I can barely remember
I do long division or algebra with long
division you know I solve equations yeah
that's the reason why I liked math
because once I got it like I I got it oh
good Algebra one pre algebra geometry
groups god yeah I like geometry because
of how it looked but I hated memorizing
everything I'm algebra cheese algebra
two manometry precalculus calculus
geometry similar logic so it's like you
have to cut it I went all the way to
[ __ ] count to in college I don't
number [ __ ] calculus
I was an econ major I had to that's why
I went into business cuz we didn't gotta
do math we just did it I couldn't get
into our business major in Riverside so
I didn't do [ __ ] busy econ why
couldn't you get into it cuz it's super
hard to get into the business major in
in Riverside high in passing a large
[ __ ] yeah that's right you want to
resize so Riverside [ __ ] is anthropology
and our business me anthropology yeah
anthropology
what about farming too probably right
yeah buildings dolls or agriculture
Agricole I should have got a UC Davis oh
yeah they have a huge Aggie program
there dude thank you what they call the
Aggies
yeah UC Davis
they haven't letterman jackets and [ __ ]
they're so cool they really do our high
school had an agricultural program in
there that that would help you go into
like he has it we had that at Gardena
high we had goats
we have mamas and in like it was like a
default program because Gardena used to
be a farm town but then all like so the
school was like a trade school like it
would teach people like how to [ __ ]
work on the farm and all that you know
what that's seeing your food yeah does
affect me a little bit because when I
saw a baby cow couldn't evil anymore
okay yeah good evil cuz like specially
how they're treated that I locked up
they don't use their muscles in [ __ ] and
that's why it's so tender I can't can do
it cuz baby baby the calves don't still
don't even feel anymore nah cuz calves
are too cute man
cows are [ __ ] ugly man cuddling with
people and sleeping those really cute
boars are ugly yeah one more thing can
we all make a date to go to the gentle
born sure is that it's a petting zoo a
huge like like farm boy it's like a huge
petting zoo you can pet like every
animal I'm for sure gonna be vegetarian
after this yeah absolute can we go I'm
hungry my carne asada so nice I like
seeing my carne asada happy I know I'll
feed the goats we may hot cheetos with
my friends I love how we started this
conversation with math and it ended with
Noel already know all right submitted by
like a light like an eyeball like a like
a boy called 9-1-1 for homework help and
the dispatcher came to his aid indiana
lafayette yeah you'll pour me a hometown
Daniel I'm sorry it's wrong
yeah Lafayette Louisiana Lafayette in
San Jose
I have a Lafayette here oh we do yeah is
it a street name yeah that's gonna be my
first son's name
Lafayette but um we got so Antonio
she's the 911 dispatcher oh thank you
yeah we
[Music]
yeah yeah so what are you what are you
learning and what do I don't know how to
do fractions either man wait was that
all I mean I thought I got you know what
pisses me off
what if someone's house was on fire
I'm sure not just one they just like
beep beep beep and you get that [ __ ]
like busy [ __ ] signal cuz she's on
the phone
I love in your imagination there's only
one person handling all the emergency is
1990 in my head
and when you call people he means 19 X
40 1990 and when you call people and
there are the phone it goes [ __ ] I
some dude in Compton named Victor
Fuentes and he's help right there cuz he
is he's heart if she would have called
me and told me I need help with math
I've been I would have been like well
you should I love you she owes fractions
I'm like dude really do expressions are
hard
how did you she learned like a week ago
like if you're ever in need of help
yeah call 9-1-1 and then so she's like
you know what I'm stressed out I think
it's about I think it's time for me to
call 9-1-1 yo this homeworks [ __ ]
hard dude that's what probably happened
I'm not lying
what is the fraction again really
actually there's some parts of a whole
like two out of three measurements that
I know how to use it I just don't know
what the words are for is it did you
guys write the number the fraction like
the number in the line under or the line
diagonal diagonal Sun wheel in the line
that I did I forgot when I would see
fractions I would be scared of it so my
eyes just went it doesn't exist are you
taking everything I won't dispatcher yep
probably I can't I can hear crazy [ __ ]
but has really affect me alright let's
do it right now I can hear you get the
same place your address sir
65 boy [ __ ] Gandhi Street boom got it
what's your emergency
it fell down some stairs that [ __ ] but
are you breathing nose like bleeding are
you look up 9-1-1 called Victor Flint is
the most gangster phone call real he's
the one that needs help
oh really you gotta come with all those
[ __ ] sirens and [ __ ] wake up the
whole neighborhood
[ __ ] because he's getting defensive
for he goes he goes well eagles are you
having trouble boy oh geez even how he
ends the phone call funky goes see goes
what's your name
Victor Fred days they say and then like
six questions and he's like there's much
information information already too much
information is too much information
I've read some crazy yeah it's like
dispatch calls on the internet I like
the high ones all those are good it was
a one that they ate like a brownie or
like we brownie it's not a stolen it's
like a mom or dad or something like that
I forgot it was a long time ago but then
they called because they thought things
like they were dying and something was
happening it does feel like you're
[ __ ] dying I thought that was it but
it was pretty fun up and shooting that's
a brownie Oprah no it was bong it but I
hadn't always aim I hadn't had a bong
hit and damn dude I remember the last
time I was so high like it felt like you
know when you're in the front of a
roller coaster and you're going down and
you're going like this like that picture
like when you're on the love I didn't
like everybody get everybody go ahead
like this and then they get that shot of
you go like that it was a continuous
just down yeah of that I'm just like in
my head I'm just like this like damn
make it stop and [ __ ] dude
so four years goes out cuz man you were
going up for me I was spinning oh my god
I was going down spinning but the
gravity was pulling me down not that way
but I was just like irritated as well
every time I get too high all I do is
try to go to sleep so I'm in bed like
this and I'm like get sober already I'm
too [ __ ] high and then in my head I'm
like
you know what the worst part is is when
somebody asks you a question but you're
just answering the question in your
[ __ ] mind and nothing's coming out
they're like hey I hate nobody it's
annoying for me because I am an
articulate human being and I want to
speak so they got will ask me some very
simple what are you going today and in
my mind I'm like you're there answer the
question in my head and then I'm at the
location I [ __ ] ate that I hated that
[ __ ] I was being so [ __ ] mad
I hate me my I like I hate it
it lets me see things from a different
perspective don't hit me see [ __ ] I
become full go to sleep and I'm hungry
that's all last time I was watching a
Moonwalker and then when I was high I
was watching I love Michael Jackson you
know and I'm like as soon as he started
performing and going through it I see
this [ __ ] is so conceited
I was just judging him the whole time
like he's like getting chased and [ __ ]
remember when he turns into clay and
[ __ ] and I'm all like damn dude he's
trying to tell you guys stop [ __ ] you're
bothering him why can't people why
couldn't people just leave him alone
what people like about us so much it
feels like I'm on a computer and I'm
moving the mouse yeah and then I move
the mouse goes like everything's to
Rails for me I liked it because it would
let me focus on a thought really yeah I
can't do it like I finally had clarity
and I'm like oh my god like I can see
clearly now I tried to change a TV
channel it took me like a meat a week
really not me I feel like I'm in [ __ ]
molasses do you mean - I don't feel
sharp at all slow motion oh you guys do
it that's amazing
see that's what I'm saying that's why I
like an alcohol better because that's
when I feel sneeze know even though but
yes the difference is for me an alcohol
where I'm drinking even though I'm dumb
as [ __ ]
I feel sharp as a dad you know I'm not
though but I feel that way
what I'm we I don't feel sharp and I
don't like that game so I want to at
least
really even though if I'm not yeah but
don't you like thinking about like the
galaxy is [ __ ] I don't like I like to
just beat out of this world you're ready
out of this world dude come back a
little I need to come back right now I'm
hovering on a satellite I want to go to
Mars and [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]